die tödlichen polizeischüsse von
Dortmund jetzt ermittelt die
Staatsanwaltschaft gegen fünf Polizisten
ein Verdacht Totschlag nach diesem
Einsatz am 8 august in der Dortmunder
Nordstadt ja dabei ist ein erst 16 Jahre
alter Senegalese getötet worden durch
Schüsse aus der Maschinenpistole
polizeischüsse warum haben die
Polizisten diesen Jugendlichen
erschossen Bild liegt jetzt der Bericht
der Staatsanwaltschaft vor
Mohammed d er kam aus dem Senegal nach
Deutschland jetzt wurde er genau hier in
Deutschland in Dortmund erschossen von
der Polizei
beerdigt wurde er jetzt in seiner Heimat
im Senegal nutzende Menschen nahmen den
Sarg in Empfang trauerten mit der
Familie des Jungen
Rückblick Montagabend vor vier Wochen
bei der Polizei in Dortmund geht ein
Notruf eines Sozialarbeiters ein ein
Mann mit einem Messer er will sich
umbringen im Innenhof der Jugendhilfe
Einrichtung ST Elisabeth wenige Minuten
später beginnt der tödliche
polizeiinsatz zunächst mit Pfefferspray
in dem geheimen Bericht der Ermittler
heißt es auf Anordnung des
dienstgruppenleiters besprühte eine
Polizeibeamtin den Verstorbenen mittels
des reitstoffsprühgeräts mit
Pfefferspray ihr raufsprang der
Verstorbene auf und bewegte sich in
Richtung von Polizeibeamten die zunächst
etwa fünf bis sechs Meter von ihm
entfernt war
daraufhin greifen die Polizeibeamten
inzwischen sind es zwölf zu einem
sogenannten Taser doch der wird offenbar
nicht richtig eingesetzt die Auswertung
der Distanz elektroimpulsgeräte hat
ergeben dass bei dem ersten Schuss ein
Stromkreis nicht hergestellt werden
konnte
weiter heißt es in dem Bericht der Taser
habe nicht dazu geführt weil Mohammed D
einen neuromuskuläre
Handlungsunfähigkeit herbeizuführen
zudem hätten die Ermittlungen nicht
ergeben dass Mohammed D klar und
verständlich dazu aufgefordert worden
sei sein Messer niederzulegen es sind
diese Kunden in denen der 16-Jährige
immer noch das Messer in der Hand hält
mit einer 15 bis 20 cm lang Klinge ob er
die Polizisten genau in diesem Moment
wirklich bedroht unklar doch genau in
diesem Moment schießt einer der
Polizisten als er etwa zwei bis drei
Meter von PK entfernt war gab dieser mit
der von ihm geführten Maschinenpistole
MP5 mehrere Sch auf den Verstorbenen ab
wobei der Verstorbene von fünf Schüssen
getroffen wurde und zwar am Kopf in der
Schulter vorne im Unterarm im Bauch und
in der Schulter hinten
Mohammed D ist lebensgefährlich verletzt
stirbt wenig später im Krankenhaus bis
Ende eines tödlichen polizei-einsatzes
eines Einsatzes der unverhältnismäßig
gewesen sein könnte die
Staatsanwaltschaft ermittelt wegen
Körperverletzung mit Todesfolge und
prüft den Verdacht des Totschlags und
auch gegen vier weitere Polizisten
dieses Einsatzes wird ermittelt
NRW-Innenminister Herbert rollt zu Bild
dass sich die Ermittlungen jetzt auch
auf viel weitere Beamte beziehen und
sich der Tatverdacht gegen den Schützen
möglicherweise verschärfen könnte
schafft eine neue Lage das zeigt auch
dass hier genau hingeschaut wird
Staatsanwaltschaft und Polizei klären
sauber auf ein tödlicher Polizeieinsatz
in Dortmund und nun ein klarer Verdacht
diese Schüsse waren nicht
verhältnismäßig
doch sprechen wir über einen Verdacht
und eben über diesen Bericht der
Staatsanwaltschaft und das tun wir mit
Rainer Wendt dem Chef der Deutschen
Polizeigewerkschaft grüß sie hat sich
bei Bild live
wir erwischen sie im Urlaub und danken
Ihnen trotzdem dass Sie bei uns sind in
diesem Moment denn das ist ein
dramatischer Fall es gab beides zunächst
im ersten Moment große Rückendeckung
dort für diesen Polizeieinsatz
gleichzeitig aber auch sofort großen
Protest im Netz ja wieder typisch die
Polizei jetzt die Fakten in diesem
Ermittlungsbericht der
Staatsanwaltschaft wie fällt ihre
Einordnung aus
und ich bin überhaupt nicht beunruhigt
und ich sehe übrigens auch keine neue
Lage die Herbert wolders tut die
Staatsanwaltschaft macht ihre Arbeit und
das macht sie sehr gründlich dass du sie
übrigens immer so das heißt sie
ermittelt und ermittelt buchstäblich in
alle Richtungen und wenn Sie jetzt den
Verdacht eines Totschlags prüft dann ist
das noch gar nicht davon ab und ist auch
keine dramatische Wende in diesem Fall
sondern das ist das das Handwerkszeug
der Staatsanwaltschaft dass sie immer
anwendet es würde ihr ja ansonsten der
verdammt der der Vorwurf gemacht werden
hinterher von den bekannten
polizeikritikern dass die
Staatsanwaltschaft hier mit der Polizei
Kumpanei übt und eben nicht in alle
Richtungen ermitteln sie macht es genau
richtig die Staatsanwaltschaft so sind
rechtsstaatliche Ermittlungen daran
überhaupt nichts Ungewöhnliches übrigens
auch nicht die Ausweitung auf die
anderen Einsatzkräfte auch das ist
absolut üblich und würde der
Staatsanwaltschaft noch einmal hinterher
zum Vorwurf gemacht werden wenn sie es
nicht
dennoch steht Totschlag dieses Wort
steht im Raum es ist ein 16 Jahre alter
Jugendlicher gestorben bei diesem Fall
ja ein 16 Jahre alter Jugendliche
Polizei mit einem langen Messer
angegriffen hat offensichtlich andere
Einsatzmittel sie haben das in ihrem
Beitrag erwähnt wie das Wetter Spray wie
das Distanz elektroimpulsgerät der
sogenannte Tesa haben nicht gewirkt und
deshalb ist es zu den tödlichen schützen
gekommen und jetzt hat die
Staatsanwaltschaft den Auftrag dieses
dramatische Geschehen bis ins kleinste
Detail nachzubereiten und auch mögliche
unverhältnismäßigkeiten zu prüfen aber
noch einmal das ist kein Vorwurf an die
Polizei sondern das ist in einem
Rechtsstaat üblich und das dauert auch
seine Zeit das wird nicht zu schnell
Ergebnissen kommen wer aber wenn jetzt
die Staatsanwaltschaft an ersten Bericht
eine Mitglieder des Innenausschusses
vorgelegt hat da zeigt sie damit nur
dass sie sehr gründlich und sehr
sorgfältig prüft und das ist ein
Rechtsstaat richtig können Sie denn nach
all dem was wir wissen nämlich dass da
beim ersten Versuch der Taser nicht
funktioniert hat das offenbar die
Ansprache an diesen Mann der damit darum
gefuchtelt hat und seit längerer Zeit
offenbar dem Hof gezeigt hat dass er
sich selber das Leben nehmen muss dass
der die Ansprache offenbar auch nicht
funktioniert hat nicht in der richtigen
Sprache was man den Beamten gar nicht
vorwerfen kann möglicherweise hat er
aber gar nicht verstanden was die
Beamten wollten so steht es ja zumindest
in diesem Ermittlungsbericht nach all
dem würden Sie sagen dieser Einsatz der
lief vorbildlich
also zunächst einmal zeigt diese Einsatz
dass die Einsatzkräfte wirklich alles
versucht haben ganz offensichtlich alles
versucht haben um den
Schusswaffengebrauch zu vermeiden wenn
das elektroimpulsgerät nicht
funktioniert hat in dem Bericht steht ja
dass der Stromkreis nicht geschlossen
werden konnte dann deutet das darauf hin
dass einer der beiden Pfeile nicht
getroffen hat es müssen ja zwei Pfeile
die mit einem dünnen Kabel mit dem Gerät
verbunden bleiben treffen und damit ein
Stromkreis geschlossen werden kann damit
eine Kontraktion der Muskulatur
stattfinden kann die den Beschuldigten
dann sofort
handlungsunfähig machen das ist
sozusagen der Idealfall wenn einer der
Pfeile nicht trifft kann das der
Stromkreis nicht geschlossen werden und
dann wirkt er auch nicht also es sollte
alles darauf hin dass wirklich sämtliche
allen anderen Einsatzmittel eingesetzt
wurden und vor allen Dingen das
wertvollste nämlich das Wort mit dem
Versuch nicht nur durch Worte sondern
auch durch Gesten den Täter zur Aufgabe
bewegen hat alles nichts genutzt und
deshalb ist es zu diesen Ereignissen
gekommen und das zu bewerten ist jetzt
die schwierige Aufgabe der
Staatsanwaltschaft die ja immer im
Verdacht steht mit der Polizei Zukunft
nein genau das hat es nie gegeben und
die Polizei ist auch angewiesen dass die
Staatsanwaltschaft versorgt wird geprüft
um hinterher auch beim Verdacht
freigesprochen zu werden dann kann der
Chef der Deutschen Polizeigewerkschaft
Rainer Wendt zu diesem ja sehr
umstrittenen Polizeieinsatz in der
NordBau der Nordstadt bei dem ein
16-Jähriger Senegalese getötet wurde
erschossen wurde danke
[Musik]